make way for the hall of famer CBS
Sports NFL analyst he stand founts who
had the Ravens and the Chiefs on Sunday
good morning Dan how are you
real good Dan good to be with you again
all right expectation level going into
the game and then after the game where
the were those expectations men on your
behalf
yeah I think they were we expected an
exciting game and that's what we got we
expected Patrick mahomes to do his thing
and he did and Lamar Jackson you know he
had a rough day because that Kansas City
defense played better than that expected
so but still the competitor and Jackson
was very evident in the way he kept
fighting and kept trying to get his team
back into it they're very aggressive in
their play calling you know John
Harbaugh is it's not like well you would
know better as he's shrinking the
playbook for Lamar Jackson or is he just
saying look I'm gonna let him play with
all the toys here no he's letting them
play with all the toys in fact
Harbaugh's term for it is the spectrum
of the offense he's got everything and
when you look at what the Ravens can do
you know they can load up with three
tight ends and put the big fullback in
there ricard and play power football and
handing it to Mark Ingram which they did
yesterday but they can also spread it
out but the puzzling thing for me in
that game is the lack of targets to wide
receivers at one point in the third
quarter a wide receiver had only caught
one pass and they really only been
targeted one time so that has to change
for Jackson to be more successful
I asked Troy Aikman this question in the
first NRL oppose it to you if somebody
hadn't seen Patrick mahomes play how
would you describe him I think backyard
school bought schoolyard type of play
the play we all started playing when we
were 10 11 12 years old and then got
into organized ball is marvelous there's
just nothing more that you know you can
say about them except maybe MVP again uh
the way
he performs is different than the
traditional quarterback and you can say
the same thing about you know Watson and
Houston and of course Jackson in
Baltimore they're enjoying the game
they're having fun with the game they're
making plays we just haven't seen before
is there a defense that somebody can
design that's going to slow down these
offenses well you know it always starts
up front obviously if you've got the
pass rush then you've got to slow down
everybody yeah the defensive line is so
important and I think if you look at
what Aaron Donald's of the Rams
did to the Browns last night that's what
the blueprint is for stopping you know
talented people on the outside as you
pressure the quarterback and you shut
down the running game so that you know
again it always comes down to better
players doesn't the team of the better
players usually win and also when you
draft these quarterbacks down it feels
like if you're drafted in the first
round
these teams expect you to play in the
first year certainly in the top ten like
Daniel Jones got a chance to showcase
his talent yesterday and I wondered you
were taking him sixth overall why would
you bring Eli Manning back if if you
know that's your future you know were
they looking for a nice handoff here
well Eli has a lot to offer and if you
watched him yesterday he was very
supportive of Jones and I think that
says a lot about Eli and his character
and also you know that the Giants may
have had that in mind I mean I had a
chance to play behind Johnny Unitas for
a brief time in San Diego a hundred
years ago and that short time for me was
so valuable because I learned so much in
such a short time so having an Eli
therefore Daniel Jones I think is huge
if you were buying stock in some of
these young quarterbacks you know aside
from the Holmes and Lamar Jackson
deshaun Watson like is there a
quarterback that you look at and you go
you know I I love what I'm seeing it
maybe they're not making headlines here
well I like what Mayfield's doing I
think he's taking that team and made it
his own
you know they've got some things to iron
out like going for fourth and nine with
a draw play and not taking advantage of
the talent around him but I think
that'll come but I think Mayfield has
got the you know the moxie and all that
and then you think about Moxie and you
go holy cow what does this mention guy
doing his first game against the Chiefs
down in the Jacksonville and he came off
the bench and was extremely accurate and
everybody was surprised but then you
know he played for Mike Leach and Mike
Leach is a quarterback guru at
Washington State
he just keeps pumping them out out of
the Palouse all the time and and minshew
is you know he's a fun guy to watch to
keep your eye on him but also you look
at the pros are adopting the college
mentality of offense or anything like
they didn't they go and study Leach when
he was at Texas Tech you know some of
these you know great NFL coach it's like
what is it about what College is doing
or Mike Leach in particular that the NFL
is adopting well they're adopting area
and adapting really for their
quarterbacks and and for their receivers
you know when you're when you're a kid
you want to play receiver don't you I
mean you want to line out wide and catch
the touchdown pass I don't think anybody
really wants to be a fullback anymore
like they get beat up too much so you
know these colleges are really
influencing the high schools obviously
because that's where they're getting
their talent so it makes sense that the
NFL is looking at well who are the best
athletes out there well they're they're
fast receivers and they're quarterbacks
I was also wondering about this with the
big numbers because you know you had air
Coryell you had this wonderful offense
but you look at these numbers now how
how much more difficult will it be to
assess who is a Hall of Famer and who
isn't when you look at the numbers put
up by wide receivers quarterbacks even
the sack numbers are going to be upped
and because you get more opportunities
for sacks so how difficult is it for the
Hall of Fame to assess who is a Hall of
Famer
well that is an excellent question and
as a selector I have to deal with that
as well this will be my fourth year
doing it and you know the numbers really
are important up to a point the
comparisons are very difficult to make a
lot of times it comes down to the
presentation learning something we don't
know about a guy and sometimes that
works against them too so you're right
about the the numbers going to just as
an example Dan do we put up a graphic
yesterday that Patrick mahomes if he
keeps up this pace he's on pace to throw
for 6,000 yards think about that it used
to be a big deal I think Marino when he
went over 4,000 like 4058 or something
and we're like oh my god
I mean Marino was so far ahead of his
time it feels like don't you well Marino
went to 5,000 yards and and I felt
really bad about that because he beat my
4800 good no oh that's right it was
5,000 48 yards for some reason I think
through 48 touching what would Marino do
in today's game well he might be on pace
to 60 good but the thing about my Holmes
is that if he has three four seconds he
is going down the field and he's going
down the field with the hopes and the
realization that something great is
going to happen and it usually does he
stand founds the hall-of-famer works for
CBS he did the Ravens Chiefs on Sunday
Antonio Brown is on the outside looking
in I just got information that he is
going to re-enroll at Central Michigan
University online does he play in the
NFL this year well I don't think he
wants to according to what he's been
saying so he's gonna need to to really
get on that online class I'm not sure
which one it's going to be but I wish
him the best because he needs some help
he does and that's what I worry
dan I think that's the bigger picture
that those around him might be failing
him because this shouldn't be about
football this should be about something
far larger than this it just feels like
there's something else in play here what
do you think well I think we'll find out
as the days go on obviously
these charges are serious and they have
to be dealt with and as you said Dan if
it's all true obviously he needs some
help and he needs it right now but you
know there's an owner or there's a coach
who's gonna go you know what he deserves
a second chance like somebody because
it's that risk reward of the talent you
know in accordance to the ratio of what
you've done wrong and he's still young
enough that he's can be in an elite
receiver I just I don't know it feels
like the things that he's saying and
doing and social media and you know this
doesn't end well here no it doesn't and
you know even though he does have the
talent and talent usually rules out it's
the off the field and it's it's all the
things you just mentioned that are wrong
and have to be corrected do you keep any
of your charger gear what did you keep
from your career my gear Jersey I have a
Jersey you know I have a Jersey from the
25th anniversary of the of the AFL
nothing else that's about it you know a
couple of mementos and things like that
what's your point
no I just curious like like what what
you keep like you know what kind of
memorabilia you keep you know I do have
one tenant that's signed by all the
players and I think that year was 1980
and the signatures are faded but the
thing is Dan in those days guys wrote
their names so they could be read okay
if you look at autographs nowadays you
have no idea just signs what you wanted
in back in back in the day though
penmanship was very important I brought
this up to my guys on the show I brought
in some programs basketball programs
that I got when I was really young
in the early 70s Jerry West Penn
ship was perfect like you're right that
these guys the only guy who had a
signature that was hard to read that was
Pistol Pete Maravich he decided pistol
but you know everybody wanted his
autograph back then Jerry West took to
him to write it so you could read it
because there are times when I'd have to
put somebody's jersey number by their
signature because I couldn't read it
I've got another one for you
I have a Willie Mays autograph and his
cursive handwriting absolutely perfect
yeah stan musial there's a lot of these
guys you look at it and you go you know
that's a beautiful beautiful autograph
here nowadays it's like not quite sure
who signed that I don't get it because
in 10 15 20 years that's gonna be tossed
away because you don't remember who it
was what game do you have next week you
already got your assignment yeah we got
a good one we got the Patriots at the
bills
what does Brady share with you when
you're in those meetings oh I can't
share with you well no but you can give
me an idea like how much does he share
with you does he ask you questions he's
great yeah I've known Tom since he was
18 years old at Sarah high school in San
Mateo I did a story on him when I was
working at channel 5 in San Francisco
and so we go back a long way obviously
he's not quite as old as I am but you
know he's always very accommodating you
know it's tough to get information out
of the Patriots but we have a real our
broadcast team Iron Eagle and Mark
Wilson Bob Fishman and evident Washburn
we have a tremendous relationship with
dole check with mr. Kraft and obviously
with Tom Brady those are obviously the
big three dan thanks for joining us
telling that I said hello and good luck
safe travels I appreciate it dan good
luck to you too mats Dan Fouts
all of Famer two-time NFL passing
touchdown leader for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]